Paulo rediscovered the Assange case and
she joins us now
Paulo remind us again why this arrest is
so important to the United States okay
al Assange is suspected of aiding a
Russian back campaign to leak emails
from the Democratic Party including
emails from president Trump's 2016 rival
Hillary Clinton and in July the Justice
Department charged 12 Russian operatives
with hacking into those computers the US
government says at least one of those
operatives was in contact with WikiLeaks
Assange and WikiLeaks have been a thorn
in the side of US law enforcement prior
to the 2016 election they've released
the CIA and military documents
throughout the years including leaking
classified documents from former
military intelligence analysts Chelsea
Manning Sao Paulo
does that mean that Assange himself will
face charges in the United States
yes Assange is lawyer just confirmed he
has been arrested on a US extradition
request well there are no current
indictments public indictment against
Assange back in November 2018 an error
in a separate Justice Department case
suggested there could be charges under
seal the prosecutor in that case wrote
the warrant would need to stay under
seal until Assange could no longer evade
arrest the US and the UK have a treaty
that actually allows for pretty easy
extradition but this still could be a
lengthy process one that Assange is
expected to fight and we are unlikely to
see Assange on US soil anytime soon Oh
interesting all right Paula thank you so
much